the uk is sweltering through a
mid-summer heat wave but the country's
political temperature has been at
boiling point for days now
and i want you to know how sad i am
following the prime minister's
resignation announcement last thursday
conservative mps of the 1922 committee
gathered to set the rules and timetable
for how to replace boris johnson
nominations will open
and close tomorrow we'll have a first
ballot on wednesday
and the second ballot is likely on
thursday what we try to do is find a
balance where we're making sure the
parliamentary stages are concluded
reasonably rapidly before the summer
recess
but we do believe we can have that
proper discussion within the party
someone has to grip this conservative
mps are aiming to whittle down a wide
field of candidates to just two by next
thursday
then over the rest of july and august
the party's 200 000 members will choose
the next leader and prime minister it's
a tight schedule but they want all this
done by early september
i think it's a wide open race and
ultimately the conservative party are
going to be worried about the the blue
on blue attacks i think that doesn't
look good to the wider electorate so
they're going they're going to want to
try and shorten that as much as they can
i think it looks like rishi sunak is the
front runner and he is the man to catch
there is one person in all of this who
has been conspicuous by his absence
boris johnson of course who's been
pretty quiet since his resignation
speech last week well he was out in
front of the cameras again on monday
where does he stand on the race to
replace him
look i i
don't want to say i any more about all
that there's a
there's a contest underway and that must
happen and you know i would
wouldn't want to damage anybody's
chances by offering my support i just
have to get on
i have to get on
meanwhile the opposition has picked up
on the generous promises of tax cuts
conservative leadership hopefuls are
falling over themselves to make
and found them laughable the arms race
at fantasy economics is well underway
over the weekend the contenders have
made more than 200 billion pounds worth
of unfunding spending commitments
200 billion
let that sink in
that's more than the annual budget of
the nhs
splurged onto the pages of the sunday
papers without a word on how it will be
paid for
fantasy will soon meet reality galloping
inflation economic stagnation and a
major war in europe just a few problems
from the prime minister's entry
it may be scorching now but for whoever
wins things will only get hotter rory
challenge al jazeera london